what are your thoughts about an upcoming
recession I mean obviously by definition
if you were to take your series seven
okay Security's license and the question
comes up they showed us the other day on
finra
definition of recession of course yeah
if you're taking a serious seven exam
the right answer is two consecutive
quarters if I answer three I failed that
question I have to put two consecutive
quarters so we're officially in
recession of where we are today
how bad is this gonna get is going to be
predicated based on are we going to do
more bailouts if we do more bailouts
that money is going to roll to the Top
If we're going to print more money it's
going to roll to the Top If we're going
to do this inflation reductionary
whatever plan um the money is going to
roll to the top I mean here's what's
crazy about myself I've made millions of
dollars in my life but
2019 or 2019 I made more money than my
entire life 2020 made more money than my
entire life including 19 2021 made more
money than my entire life including 2020
uh 2020 2022 so far more money than all
of those years combined what happened
with these money they printed they throw
in the market it rolls up guys like me
are like print more if you want to but
it's not a good thing
you know the the right solution today
for us to overcome the challenges we're
facing no one would win White House if
they ran the right policies today the
right policies that America really needs
would never win the election today never
it would be a popular policy you need to
run some shitty policies to convince
people that you're going to give them
something for free to win today that's
what's unfortunately attractive today
but if somebody got up and said hey guys
let me tell you
uh here's what I'm running for I'm going
to make sure our military gets stronger
in the area of cyber warfare and bio
Warfare we're going to take our spending
a little bit more on that side uh we're
gonna do what we can with taxes we're
going to take some of these resources
and try to pay off our debt and uh the
next four years our goal is to get some
of our redo some of our debt and we all
got to get to work so you're not going
to see me too much we all have something
we got to do you got to pull your own
little red wagon I got to do the same
and let's let's bring America back to
what it was before wait what do you mean
I don't have any policies
we need to take some policies off the
table we need to get to work that
wouldn't you would never win with that
you know what you would never win with
that so you know in regards to recession
you know I think it's a great time you
know you got to pay attention to what's
happening with inventory uh and sf90
Ferrari a year ago you would have a
three of them in a market to buy today
there's 35 40 of them certain rookie
card uh Michael Jordan was selling for
700 000 a year and a half ago Vegas Dave
and I both of us said this is not going
to go any higher oh it's going to hit a
million bucks it's back down to 150 to
200 000 card going from 700 000 to 150
that's that's a 75 drop off yeah you
know certain you know from October of
2021 I'm sure you've seen this one to
today October 2021 to today eight months
discount stores in America their sales
volume is up 71 sales is up 71 why are
people going to Discount stores and and
they did a research to see that top
earners are showing up there before then
they did before they consider a top
earner somebody that makes eighty
thousand dollars or more they didn't
have the this many people making 80k or
more going to the discount stores they
are today why are they going what are
they afraid of what are they preparing
for so you know have we hit the part
where people have fully lost their
optimism where everything's going to be
okay we're not there yet have we hit the
fully paranoia no people are a little
suspicious but no one's yet paranoid and
no one's yet scared so there is no
scared opportunities today people are
still greedy if you enjoyed this video I
give a keynote a few weeks ago in Las
Vegas specifically on the topic of
cracking a code to content creation if
you've not seen it click here to watch
it take care everybody bye
foreign